tokyo game show is always a massive
spectacle for the public it's all these
boobs trying to clamor with various
lights that noises trying to get your
attention and hold on to it as long as
they can and TGS 2015 was no exception
this is my second tgs and by far the
coolest thing i saw this year was for
the capcom booth they had a section for
umbrella core which they just announced
and there was all these guns on display
and you could actually shoot them in a
shooting range they were pellet guns but
here those pellets are metal they're
doing some damage I couldn't believe
they even got away with putting that in
in the booth but you get in line and
basically they give you these plastic
goggles to put on and they let you have
one of the guns actually from the game I
had a Beretta and you shoot it at these
zombie place holders and as you shoot
them that kind of fall down and it gives
you a pretty nice feeling to shoot a gun
at an event like this something I've
never done before certainly it
definitely held my attention and it's
amazing just to have to have like 20
bullets kind of shoot as many zombies as
you can it was a very unique experience
that I've never ever had not just at TGS
but any event ever never shot a gun
before
I love every chance to come to Tokyo the
Tokyo Game Show is so much fun even
though some of the games maybe aren't
what we might see III or other events
and I really can't even just choose one
thing to my favorite things where a
grand bleu fantasy it's a game that I'd
never even heard of and it's just a
mobile game put the set up the stage
they had for it this massive airship I
mean it was obviously designed by the
characters by the team behind final
fantasy and it's called grand bleu
fantasy but here it's just a mobile game
but the booth where it was larger than
the entire space for Sony like just
seeing that booth made me want to play
this free to play mobile game but that
wasn't the only thing that was fun i
also finally got a chance to try out
summer lesson which i don't think was a
new demo and something we'd heard about
before but was for the newly dub
playstation vr formerly the Morpheus and
I'm already a VR convert I love getting
to try vr in its different forms and
it's still missing like being able to
interact with things when you touch
something in it doesn't touch you back
like it still kind of takes you out of
the moment but some are love like the
way that the graphics look it's just so
incredibly realistic that when this
person that you're standing next to kind
of leans in and like hey how do i read
this like you're you're being her
japanese teacher like you almost expect
to feel her head like touching right
next to yours like the graphics on it
just make it look so amazing so
realistic and those are just some of the
two of them oh my most favorite things
from TGS this year
so this was my first TGS I've never been
here before in a minute okie before it
was really overwhelming and there were
so many cool games to play but my
absolute favorite thing was the trico
wall the developers of the Last Guardian
set up this screen installation where
you could walk up to the screen and
interact with trico who's the big bird
dog monster from the Last Guardian it
uses the same way I programming that
they're using for trico in the game I
don't know where the sensors were in
that giant screen but it was so awesome
you could walk up to him and you would
wait and he'd come over and he'd look at
you and he yell or whatever you want to
call that sound and the gates would open
and he leaned up against the gate and it
was so beautiful and so awesome you
could say that this is the first
playable instance of the Last Guardian
and that's why it's my favorite thing at
TGS
this is my 60 GS so the spectacle of all
the lights and the Japanese craziness
doesn't really affect me anymore what
does affect me though is playing cool
games and took a game show is obviously
all about the game so playing stuff like
min agree online for the first time even
though it's out in a month I was still
stoked to play it street fighter 5
getting to play the new characters and
being you know one of the first people
to do that it's really great playing
Dark Souls 3 and blood-borne the old
hunters you know for the first time ever
rocking up to the star wars battlefront
stage even though they weren't showing a
new demo 64 people coming out on stage
to like shoot each other on hot was
awesome so TGS is all about the games
for me
you